[Musique]
c'est ici que nous abordons les
questions posées par les téléspectateurs
il y en a une qui concerne la menace de
réchauffement est ce que l'activité de
ces volcans ne peut pas devenir un jour
tels qu'ils fassent fondre la glace
autour vous voyez les conséquences
auxquelles pense des tas de gens c'est à
dire que si jamais quelqu'un calculé
niveau de la mer
oui si jamais la la la grande banquise
fond le niveau des mers va monter 200 m
on y attachons pas les volcans qui le
feront ce qui peut le faire c'est la
pollution industrielle
expliquez-nous comment est bien la
pollution et du ciel dégage des
quantités de produits chimiques de toute
nature dont une énorme quantité de gaz
carbonique et c'est claude qui nous
disait tout à l'heure qu'il s'agit de
plusieurs dizaines de milliards de
mètres cubes 20 milliards de tonnes par
ans la quantité de co2 que l'homme
rejette la suite et de ses activités et
et cette quantité de cette chronique se
propage dans l'atmosphère l'atmosphère
et risque de faire de la master une
espèce de sang il ya aller l'histoire
déchets aux deux banques sous entendu
c'est vrai on en fabrique beaucoup mais
une des y'a quand même des correcteurs
automatiques
il ya d'abord la végétation qui les
consume tout en plus oui je suis la
forêt on m'attendait il ya donc d'abord
la végétation qui est inquiète un
correcteur nature et à lhassa et ensuite
il ya le séant alors il est certain que
nous menacions si en simultanément les
forêts et la surface de l'océan qui la
surface 2
tahar échanges bon alors mais si on
avait la sagesse de planter des arbres
en même temps qu'on brûle du pétrole
vraiment pété désordre dans
l'antarctique et n'importe où mais y'a
pas besoin que ça dans l'antarctique
nations ont patienté au lieu de détruire
les forêts françaises ont les protéger
d'une part comme on en augmenter la
surface
si au lieu de détruire la forêt
amazonienne on la protège des 6 ou le
détruire les forêts de bornéo de livno
de jacques dessus matra et de l'afrique
centrale on partageait ses forêts il n'y
aurait pas de danger avec le gaz
carbonique et au contraire il y aurait
de plus en plus d'oxygène mais on ne le
fait pas on protège pas et pour faire
des profits colossaux
on massacre nos forêts alors on lui dira
si j'ai bien compris que du fait de
l'existence de cette masse énorme de gaz
carbonique dans l'atmosphère
il ya une convergence qui fait au niveau
de la niveau du pôle non il doit y avoir
un effet de serre général réchauffement
de 2 ou 3 degrés deux de la température
de l'atmosphère diffusion fusion d'une
énorme quantité de glace polaire ou ses
biens au sud qu'au nord est et glace de
montagne et risque de réchauffement donc
à cause du réchauffement de 3 degrés de
moyenne suffisent n'est ce pas est
montée des eaux est donc noyer noyade de
toutes les deux toutes les côtes basses
jets de new york est le havre et
marseille et nice est longue nous avions
pris note en train de paniquer les
populations là
[Musique]